nuevas medidas día tras día la situación
sanitaria se vuelve más tensa en europa
con países que ven sus cifras de
contagios subir exponencialmente en
france el portavoz del gobierno que
abriera tal declaró que un micro no
representa uno de cada tres casos en
parís y por ello las medidas no pueden
esperar la situación de los hospitales
está tensa con cerca de 16.000 personas
hospitalizadas y más de 3000 en
reanimación anunció que el proyecto de
ley sobre nuevo paso sanitario será
debatido el próximo lunes en un consejo
extraordinario de ministros las
frustraciones también siguen y las
expresiones de rechazo suben de tono
como en esta ciudad de magdeburg donde
los manifestantes se enfrentaron
violentamente con la policía lo que
provocó arrestos de quienes se oponen a
la intención del gobierno de prohibir a
delegaciones para hacerle frente a las
consecuencias económicas de las medidas
restrictivas reino unido anunció el
lanzamiento de un paquete de apoyo de
mil millones de libras destinadas a las
empresas en primer lugar para proteger
los puestos de trabajo y las empresas de
los sectores de la hostelería y el
gobierno va a introducir un paquete de
subvenciones por valor de 1.000 millones
de libras también pondrá 3 millones de
libras a disposición del sector cultural
otra buena noticia para los europeos
podrán seguir viajando libremente con el
pasaporte cubit la unión europea anunció
este martes que el pase sanitario será
válido para desplazarse dentro del
bloque por un periodo de nueve meses
después de la última dosis de vacuna
recibida medida que entrará en vigencia
a partir del primero de febrero